ще
раздо суільство
наіки друзі всі привітаємо справжніх
козаків і подякуємо що ми разом разом
боронимо Україну разом будуємо Україну і
рухаємо її в Європу і господь з нами
Олександр Валентинович окрема подяка за
погоду велике спасибі Дякую що ми
зібралися і Разом до перемоги Слава
[оплески]
Україні Ну що ж друзі черговий раз
запрошую всіх займати свої
місця я щиро радий всіх вас
вітати Мене звуть Святослав Бойко Я
сьогодні буду з вами як модератор як
ведучий
як один зі спікерів дуже приємно бачити
знайомі обличчя дуже радісно бачити нові
обличчя Наша команда росте наша сім'я
росте і це тішить адже в нас друзі вірна
стратегія в нас правильні пріоритети у
нас правильні єдиноправильні цінності і
наша головна цінність - Це вільна
незалежна європейська
Україна я щиро радий всіх вас вітати і
черговий
етап
з'їзду європейської солідарності
Оголошую відкритим для виконання
державного гімну України запрошую до
мікрофона соловейка золотий голос
європейської солідарності народного
депутата України Софію
федину Ще не вмерла
[музика]
України ні
слава ні
воля Ще нам браття
[музика]
українці
усміхнеться
доля
Згинуть наші
воріженьки я
кроса на
сонці
запанує міми браття у
своїй
сторонці Душу й
тіло ми
положим за
нашу
[музика]
свободу ду і
покажем що ми
браття
козацького
роду душу і
тіло ми
положим за
нашу
[музика]
свободу І пока
жем що ми
браття
[музика]
козацького
роду Слава Україні
Слава Нації смертьга Україна понад
усе Софія фетина
Дякую
друзі брати і сестри Сьогодні в нас є
особливий
день 7 років тому 7 червня
2014 року Петро Порошенко очолив країну
і він зробив
то в найскладніший час історії
Української держави він взяв на себе
відповідальність за
країну
Сьогодні ми згадаємо як це
було що ми мали на старті чого вдалося
здобути чого ми досягли важкою працею
Кров'ю і потом але головне завдання
нашого з'їзду нашого зібрання друзі це
подивитися вперед подивитися в майбутнє
в майбутнє з опорою на нашу з вами
українську історію і на наш твердий
монолітний фундамент який ми заклали
разом у
14му1му роках і ви всі чудово знаєте що
нам є чим
пишатися невипадково з'їзд відбувається
саме тут на
артзаводі платформа
це символічне місце як
приклад
перетворення зі старого радянського
занедбаного
заводу в креативний
простір проходячи галереями артзаводу ви
бачили багато всяких цікавих
активностей ви бачили майстерки ви
бачили спортивні активності також Хочу
наголосити що ми сьогодні проводимо
разом з благодійним фондом таблеточки ми
проводимо аукціон тому ви можете
долучитися маєте можливість долучитися
до доброї справи домогти допомогти
онкохворим діткам і отримати за це
хороший пам'ятний подаруночок Я думаю що
кожному з вас це буде цікаво і
приємно нас зібралося сьогодні дуже
багато але так сталося що не всі хто
бажав бути тут особисто змогли сьогодні
до нас
приєднатися з
побажаннями з відеопобажаннями з
відеозверненнями до делегатів з'їзду до
гостей до всіх нас виступило багато
відомих українців відома українська
письменниця класик української
літератури Оксана забушко та її завжди
влучні і актуальні слова до європейської
солідарності увага на екрани сердечні
вітання всім учасникам високодостойного
зібрання хочу донести до вас ту емоцій
психологічну атмосферу яка сьогодні
либонь об'єднує всіх в Україні хто
заклопотаний її майбутнім Це відчуття
людей які бачать як їхня країна подібно
до того
бла-блакару який раптом
серединочі збочивши з шляху женеться
десь в темряві лісом по бакая
за кермом весело гегоче просто от зграя
обкурених підлітків а пасажири з жахом
роззираються довкола чи є дорослі котрі
могли би перехопити кермо і вивести
країну на той шлях яким вона гордо
рухалася ще вчора
коли приємно було бути українцем коли
весь світ дивився на нас на нашу країну
з Надією в якій хотілося жити і для якої
хотілося працювати І от ми знову
сповзаємо нас знову перестають сприймати
як суб'єктів світової історії і знову
молодь починає міркувати куди звідси
втікати з цієї країни яка стала отим
самим Сказати б тілом без голови як
говорилося ще в слові ополку Ігоре я
бажаю вам
стати такою об'єднавчою головою для
цілої
[музика]
України з'їзд європейської солідарності
також привітала особливо символічна
людина Голова Європейської Ради який
дуже багато зробив для євроінтеграції
України спільно з президентом Петром
Порошенком Дональд Туск в той час була
сформована унікальна коаліція на
підтримку України і зроблені
по-справжньому історичні кроки в
європейській інтеграції До речі річницю
безвізу Ми дуже скоро будемо відзначати
11 червня А це відкриті двері у світ для
України запрошую до слова голову
комітету з питань європейської
інтеграції Івану Климпуш
ценсадзе
дорогі друзі шановний Петро
олексійовичу шановні посестри і шановні
побратими з Європейської
солідарності перед тим як зачитати слово
звернення Дональда туска керівника
європе ї народної партії до нашого
з'їзду хотіла би нагадати усім нам що я
думаю ми всі переконені що ми маємо
конкретну дорожню карту реформ А це
угода про асоціацію ми знаємо з вами Що
Європейський союз - це багато в чому про
торгівлю і Бізнес але ми вже навчилися
цим користатися і Європейський союз
завдяки нашим з вами зусиллям став нашим
головним торговельним партнером Але
найголовніше про що йдеться в
європейській інтеграції це про цінності
і саме завдяки цінностям європейської
інтеграції ми з вами протягом
останніх років починаючи з 14-го не
стали малоросійським федеральним округом
Російської Федерації бо ми з вами
рухалися відповідно до цінностей ми
рухалися повертаючись додому і наше з
вами завдання це Власне кажучи тримати
країну так щоби Нам вдалося Не звернути
з цього шляху бо ми з вами знаємо як
добиватися угоди Петро Олексійович знає
як її підписувати ми з вами знаємо і
вміємо її реалізовувати і ми з вами
маємо бачення як повернутися додому а
тепер до слів пана
Шановний пане голово дорогий Петре
шановні учасники з'їзду дорогі друзі від
імені європейської народної партії я
радий вітати вас делегатів нашої
сестринської політичної партії
європейська Солідарність і передати
слова подяки за ваші щирі зусилля у
розбудові європейської демократичної
незалежної України сьогодні і Україна і
Європейський союз переживають період
складних системних викликів від
коронавірусної пандемії яка змінила наше
життя вразила наші економіки та
соціальні системи до безпекових загроз
агресивної поведінки Росії посилення
авторитарних режимів Путіна та Лукашенка
ці проблеми важкі і потребують потужних
ефективних А головне солідарних
відповідей і пошук тих відповідей- наше
спільне завдання будьте певні що
Євросоюз А головне представники нашої
найвпливовішої політичної родини
європейської народної партії незмінно
підтримує український народ у вашій
боротьбі за суверенітет за територіальну
цілісність і європейське майбутнє ми
вдячні європейській солідарності та її
керівництву за збереження лідерства у
просуванні демократичного та
європейського порядку денного в
українському політичному і суспільному
житті за просування наших спільних
європейських цінностей та активну роль у
діяльності родини європейської народної
партії дорогі учасники з'їзду я бажаю
вам плідної роботи змістовних дискусій
світлих ідей Які зміцнять ваші позиції у
політичному житті України і сприятимуть
процвітанню держави через інтеграцію до
ЄС і безпеці через інтеграцію до НАТО ви
можете Завжди розраховувати на підтримку
європейської народної партії в цій
складній боротьбі за наше спільне
майбутнє я залишаюсь твердо переконаним
що немає Європи без України Дякую за
увагу
Слава Україні президент європейської
народної партії Дональд
Туск насправді пан Туск не єдиний лідер
великої
політичної родини який привітав наш
сьогоднішній з'їзд а тому я попрошу
включити також звернення колишнього
прем'єр-міністра Канади пана Стефана
гарпера який сьогодні очолює міжнародний
демократи
Союз нашу всесвітню велику родину
дякуюe
ces We count you to defend our sharedes
to Stand Against
externalvention and to safegard the
soverety of ukra as you continue your
crial National Mission
iduмочві з нами Європа з нами а значить
У нас попереду багато перемог Слава
Україні також друзі Ми дякуємо нашим
міжнародним партнерам які присутні тут а
це представництво фонду Конрада
аденауера в Україні міжнародному
республіканському інституту
національному демократичному інституту А
зараз друзі ще раз увага на екран
привітання від габріели бауман голови
фонду Конрада аденауера в північних
країнах євро
шановні пане Порошенко шановні учасники
з'їзду партії дорогі друзі Я з радістю
Вітаю ваш конгрес від мого імені та
надсилаю найкраще побажання від фонду
конада аденаура у
Швеції незважаючи на те що я залишила
Київ майже два роки тому я все ж дуже
уважна зти жу за українською
політикою на моїй пам'яті Я часто
повертаюся до вирішальних років після
14го року коли були проведені масштабні
реформи під час президентства Петра
Порошенка та європейської більшості у
верховнії ради під керівництвом партії
європейська
Солідарність я мала честь працювати з
багатьма із вас до 19-го року
європейська Солідарність сьогодні - це
сильна
проєвропейська партія чітко орієнтована
на пошук реалістичних рішень для
українського народу та відкрита для
обговорення шляхів вирішення викликів
разом з європейськими
партнерами у партії є фантастична
молодіжна організація в якій працюють
дуже віддані молоді
люди Я завжди вірила що можна створити
політичну
партію яка не лише пов'язана з тим що
лідером повинен бути президент
України на сьогоднішній день ваша партія
стала важливим і стабільним учасником
партійного
ландшафту Україні я бажаю всього
найкращого для конгресу та важливої
політичної роботи в майбутньому ви
завжди можете розраховувати на нашу
підтримку дуже вам
дякую Ну що ж Друзі а тепер ми
переходимо до роботи з'їзду безперечно
головним викликом 2014 року стала війна
і захист країни частина якої була вже
окупована Петро Порошенко почав
створення української армії і сьогодні
всі визнають що українська армія одна з
кращих і найсильніших у Європі А
європейська Солідарність стала тією
політичною силою довкола якої гуртуються
люди які чудово знають ціну
Незалежності ветерани і волонтери
запрошую до слова ветерана
російсько-української війни депутата
Київської міської ради від європейської
солідарності Олександра
погребиського Шановний пане
президент шановні
делегати шановні
гості
Дежавю Дежавю - це те що найчастіше
відчуваєш
зараз Дежавю 2014
року коли економіка країни була
зруйнована ко від ЗСУ залишилась тільки
назва А на
порозі стояв сильний ворог
зараз Сьогодні я радий
представити нову громадську
організацію
ветеранську з
назвою Брати по
[оплески]
зброї ми не створюємо
альтернативу альтернативну військову
партію Ми будемо підтримувати обраний в
14-му
році нашим верховним
головнокомандувачем курс на побудову
сильної
розвиненої заможної національної
свідомої
України Україна понад усе для нас це не
гасло це модель жави яка поважає
себе свою мову
історію
культуру яка здатна захищати
себе і створити сприятливі умови для
захисту своїх
громадян і дотримуватись насамперед
власних
інтересів і нікому не дозволяти
вказувати як нам
жити з позиції міфічного старшого
брата Для нас це національна ідея і в
цьому Ми безсумнівні націоналісти як і
будь-який
усвідомлений громадянин
України був такий справжній Ветеран Джон
кенеді він сказав під час своєї
президентської
інавгурації такі
слова Не питай що твоя
країна може зробити для
тебе запитай що ти можеш зробити для
своєї
[оплески]
країни він був абсолютно
правий пора об'єднати сили людей які
довели свою
вірність країні в бою і рятували країну
від
некомпетентності зради і
розчарування Саме ці люди не дозволять
віддати продати і закреслити те за що
вони
воювали досить ховатися за нав'язану нам
аполітичність і нескінче
чистити
кулемет пора об'єднувати тих хто вміє
правильно діяти а не тільки правильно
говорити і йти до мети до
перемоги разом крок за кроком не
відступаючи Слава
нації
дорогі друзі Я хотів би запросити на цю
сцену всіх ветеранів антитерористичної
операції ветеранів війни проти агресії
Росії прошу всі хто воював всі хто
боронив і боронить нашу
державу всіх то зараз в військовій формі
і ті хто Без неї Олександр Валентинович
прошу на
сцену Михайло Микола прошимо на
сцену і зал Я хочу почути потужні
Оплески так як Вся Україна аплодує
збройним силам України нашим воїнам
Нашим
героям гарантом
суверенітету територіальної цілісності і
незалежності нашої держави подивиться
віхоті подивиться які вони красиві які
вони
сильні саме вони готові дати
відсіть будь-якому
ворогу який наважиться напасти на нашу
державу
це те що ми з вами
Наша команда
добровольці
волонтери український народ створили в
14му-15му роках і яку ми Захистимо і
нікому не дамо
знищити Слава збройним силам
України слава волонтерам і добровольцям
слава слава слава і слава Україні героя
Слава і ми вітаємо нову громадську
організацію яка сьогодні задекларувала
про своє створення і є і залишається і
буде дуже-дуже потужною і сильною Прошу
ще раз привітати наших воїнів І
подякувати їм за те що сьогодні і завжди
вони з нами вони з
Україною
[музика]
зродились ми
з великої години З пожеж війни і полум'я
вогнів плекав нас біль за долю
України кормив нас Гнів і людь на
ворогів плекав нас біль за долю
ворогів
і ось і демо в бою
життєвому тверді міцні не зламнімов
граніт бо плач не дав Свободи ще нікому
А хто
борець той здобуває світ бо плачне дав
Свободи ще нікому А хто боре
той здобуває світ веде нас бій героїв
наших Слава для нас
закон найвищий то наказ
Соборна
українська є держава вільна й
міцна відсяяну по Кавказ
Соборна
українськає держа
вільна й
міцна від Сяну по
Кавказ Слава
Україні
Слава Браво Дуже дякую ще раз Дякуємо
нашим
[оплески]
воїнам
[музика]
пере
велика шана і уклін нашим
військовим ви знаєте стояло це
товариство на сцені і я розумію що нам є
на кого опертися нам є на кого рівнятися
і нам Є з ким боронити наш
край тоді коли на фронті українська
армія звільняла український Донбас
всередині країни почалися складні
реформи реформи які покликані на
пострадянському
рунті створити сучасну європейську
державу Влада представники
громадянського суспільства українська
інтелігенція багато відомих діячв
культури вони всі були об'єднані прямим
діалогом в якому народжувалась істина
про важливість діалогу та про те чому
варто не спати і бути пильними відомий
український
письменник Юрій Андрухович спеціально
для європейської солідарності увага на
екрани діалог із владою в Україні не
така проста та штука і Наша історія
Небагато таких періодів
знала але він був і він був дуже
продуктивний і це відбивалося і на тому
загальному якби суспільному нерві
суспільному настрої який формував
волонтерський рух який формував
добровільчі батальйони Але який також
формував особливу культурно-мистецьку
активність Виникнення нових фестивалів
залу мистецьких проектів великий якби
Стрибок у гору і вперед у
книговидавничій справі звичайно
кінематограф на сьогодні цей цього
діалогу просто немає тому що влада в
Україні
ее його уникає Вона виходить із тих
навиків якими володіє А це навики
телевізійного шоу бізнесу взаємодія із
владою яка була Можлива і навіть Бажана
в попередній політичній
каденції на сьогодні ну фактично
зупинена але слід увесь час бути на
поготові на поготові тому що серіал
повертаюся знову до цього серіал
передбачає несподівані дуже ходи цим
несподіваним ходом може завтра бути Щось
таке що ми не дай боже прокинемося в
іншій країні тому засинати не можна і як
я вже сказав у весь час стежити і бути
на поготові
[музика]
друзі запрошую до вітального слова
відомого дипломата перекладача майстра
влучного слова Дмитра чекалкіна з його
баченням сучасної української політики
Дмитре будь
ласка олексійвич пані Марина рідна
громада європейської солідарності ви
знаєте Мій друг Олександр погребицький
згадав важкі часи для нашої держави в
мене теж така рефлексія
з'явилась я в цьому місті побував перший
раз 20 років тому це були абсолютно
занедбані покинуті приміщення
дарнивського шовкового
комбінату мене сюди привів легендарний
ізраїльський льотчик мій товариш один з
тих інвесторів яких я сюди залучав Як
колишній український дипломат і казав
тут буде великий розважальний культурний
торговельний центр Я кажу оферти з
божеволів який тут торговий центри які
абсолютно занедбані приміщен Тим більше
нагада я нагадаю вам ці часи на
Майдані вирує Україна без Кучми Україна
в повній політичній ізоляції це зелене
непорозуміння стрибає по сценах в Москві
і падає на коліна перед Путіним і благаю
його забрати його з цієї нещасної
України Володимир Володимирович тільки
від вас залежить моя доля заберіть мене
звідси ви знаєте коли
[музика]
народжується людина в метричних
свідоцтвах
пишуть де вона народилася пишуть коли
вона народилася біль менш точно пишуть
від кого вона
народилася але не пишуть Навіщо вона
народилася є одна відповідь на це
питання ніколи не треба скаржитись на
важкі часи Ти для того і народжений щоб
їх
покращити немає в цій країні сьогодні
іншої сили з якою можна було пов'язувати
наші Надії на покращення нашого життя на
вихоід з цієї кризи коли завела нас ця
зелена
команда знаєте рік тому це зелене
непорозуміння сказало що він майстер
спорту чи там чемпіон по боротьбі з
коронавірусом Ми бачили цю майстерність
бачили ці досягнення це десятки
тисяч життів українців а науковці
стверджують що не десятки тисяч А
півтори сотні тисяч наших
співвітчизників які стали жертвою цієї
зеленої команди вони стверджували що
вони виведуть нас з кризи що сюди потік
інвестицій розпочнеться з їх правління
Ми бачили
результати цієї популістичної діяльності
ви знаєте два роки тому ще Я назвав
дійсно Зеленського
чемпіоном чемпіоном
по популізму чемпіоном з знірства
лицемірства та брехні І вони дійсно
доводять що вони достойні цього
титулу але нагадаю що панове ми з вами і
народжені для того щоб покращити ці
часи в Святому письмі є відомий вислів
що дізнайтеся правду і правда зробить
нас
вільними на нас покладена величезна
відповідальність донести правду до
мільйонів наших співвітчизників і ми це
зробимо Слава
Україні
Слава Друзі на цьому длі ми згадуємо
вагомі зміни і реформи які нам довелося
робити тоді в роки українських перемог і
тут варто особливо відзначити
децентралізацію Коли Україна нарешті
позбулася радянського устрою і стала
державою справжнього місцевого
самоврядування і зараз вітальне слово
від міського голови столиці України
Віталія Кличка друзі увага на
екрани від партії удар Вітаю учасників
з'їзду європейської солідарності
переконаний сьогодні всі проєвропейські
сили повинні зробити все для
незворотності України з Європейського
шляху
розвитку бо майбутнє нашої держави у
Великій європейській родині і
український народ свій вибір
зробив Ми повинні бути сильними і
наполегливими щоб побудувати успішну
заможню і європейську
Україну Як би не було складно наша
держава не повинна втратити шанс на
демократичне і вільне
майбутнє Вірте в себе Вірте в
Україну творення України як європейської
держави громад цей процес потребував
твердої політичної волі передача
повноважень і коштів з центру в регіони
те чого ніхто не робив до Петра
Олексійовича і то є факт І То є правда
про децентралізацію місцеве
самоврядування про те де ми знаходимося
в цьому процесі сьогодні зараз нині
розповість міський голова чудового міста
Рівне від європейської солідарності
Олександр
[оплески]
Третяк шановний Петре
олексійовичу Марину Анатоліївну і всі
учасники цього прекрасного з'їзду Щиро
вітаю і вітання від прекрасного міста
[оплески]
Рівне
дійсно одна із найуспішніших реформ
після революції гідності котра була
закладена саме Петром олексійовичем І
його командою сьогодні дає хороші і
яскраві показники
розвитку наших громад намі ях реформа
котра була чіткою і ключовою
позицією партії європейської
солідарності сьогодні для всієї України
показує що передача повноважень на місця
до місцевого самоврядування це одна із
ключових і
вкрай потрібних
реформ в
Україні надзвичайно важливо було її і
нам продовжити і втілювати далі на
місцях і сьогодні можу сказати що в
нашому прекрасному місті у місті Рівному
Ми
сьогодні продовжуємо ті процеси і
намагаємось якомога краще і
більше Спілкуючись з людьми доносити цю
парадигму мислення що саме на місцях
саме громади є тими
рушіями змін котрі творять зміни на
місцях
Ви знаєте не
так давно коли ми розпочали роботу дуже
багато було зроблено саме в різних
напрямках по оновленню влади в нашому
місті це один із пріоритетів був для
нашої команди для оновленої команди і
перезавантаженої європейської
Солідарності в місті Рівне та в
Рівненській
області Саме на місцях ми маємо багато
дієвих та активних
рошіїв
змін ви
знаєте сьогодні чи не в кожному виступі
згадується про дуже одну ключову
річ свого часу дуайта
ізенхауер в повоєнний час коли
завершилась Друга Світова зібрав усіх
своїх друзів і не дуже і сказав шановні
проблеми викликів так багато а
відповідей на них так мало що нам
допоможе
лише тяжка Праця і
Бог саме на місцях наші українці наші
працьовиті люди є рушіями
змін ви знаєте те що не вдавалось
зробити раніше ми зробили буквально дуже
швидко і в цей особливо пандемічний
виклик коли в наших лікарнях не було
можливості приймати уже людей тому що
було надто гостро питання поставало із
забезпеченням саме фонд Петра Порошенка
допомагав нашим лікарням на місцях
розвивати допомогу для людей саме для
нас як нової влади в пріоритеті було
зробити Буквально за кілька тижнів те що
влада не могла зробити протягом року ми
забезпечили нашу центральну місь лікарню
найбільшою в Україні кисневогенеруючою
станцією котра була важлива як повітря і
в прямому і переносному сенсах Наша
команда європейської солідарності на
місцях включилась в багато процесів по
змінах які вкрай важливі сьогодні з
розвитку нашого
міста децентралізація справді дала
серйозні важалі впливу на
місцях Ми створюємо сьогодні агенцію
розвитку міста котра має стати
ключовою нішею в розвитку міста яка
стане свого
роду мізками процесів в нашому місті і
вже за допомогою наших партнерів було
написано проект і ми здобули
європейський грант на 200 000 євро для
роботи в нашому місті в сфері очищення
води Зараз ми активно по ємо
розвивати ті позиції які вкрай необхідні
для залучення людей на місцях тому хочу
подякувати Петру олексійовичу команді
європейської солідарності за неймовірно
важливі фундаментальні основи місцевого
урядування яке вкрай важливо сьогодні
зберегти І не дати його зруйнувати тому
що сьогодні є багато змін від
центральної влади щоби знову перейняти
на себе якісь обов'язки ще якісь важелі
впливу і керувати певними процесами на
місцях але Давайте збережемо те що було
дане те що було зроблено і щоби наша
країна справді стала країною
європейських цивілізованих змін і нехай
нам все
вдасться Слава
[оплески]
Україні
Дякую на доброму слові друзі Я це хотів
сказати ще на
початках на початку нашої з вами
роботи сьогодні з нами є не тільки
представники європейської солідарності а
і представники дружніх для нас
політичних партій громадських
організацій і приємно було сьогодні
побачити представника фракції голосу у
Верховній Раді Романа
Костенка Оплески друзі Дякую
вам фракції європейської Солідарності в
місцевих радах це Сучасні підходи до
управління містами та
самоврядування це про
інновації та
ініціативи європейської солідарності у
Одесі розповість депутат Одеської
міської ради Петро
Обухов
Всім привіт із Сонячної
Одеси сьогодні 7 років як ми почали
новітню історію України ми змінюємо 7
років наші міста села нашу країну я
трохи Хочу поділитися своїм досвідом в
минулому році були місцеві вибори і
багато з нас перемогли зелених Особисто
я переміг зеленого кандидата набравши
більше
голосів
На жаль місцеве телебачення вмирає Два
роки тому я започаткував свій
youtubeканал і після цього мене почали
пізнавати люди на вулицях А хоча я ходив
на телебачення і на телебаченні це не
працювало робіть YouTube канали
висвітлюют місцеві проблеми шляхи їх
вирішення коли були вибори Я ходив по
дворах спілкувався з людьми і літні люди
казали що вони бачили мене по телевізору
але я зрозумів співкувавшись з ними що
вони називають телевізор YouTube зараз
YouTube став телевізором тому Йдіть в
YouTube Йдіть в Instagram Йдіть в
Facebook спілкуйся там спілкуйтеся там з
людьми це
працює але в багатьох в нас вже є влада
на місцях і ми вже можемо робити зміни в
наших містах і
селах Минулого тижня в Одесі на вихідних
запрацювала велика пішохідна зона і це
здобуток нашої команди наша фракція в
міській раді зробила Це тисячі людей
десятки
людей були щасливі прогуляти з центром
міста і це дуже легко зробити і це
рішення які побачать усі також робіть
смуги громадського транспорту робіть
велодоріжки зробіть математичне
моделювання транспорту вашому місті і
містяні вам віддячать
через два роки будуть вибори і поки
Зелена Влада буде роз розказувати нам
казки ми будемо працювати і прийдемо до
людей з результатами все буде Україна
[оплески]
Дякую Петре інновації та готовність
відповідати на виклики європейська
Солідарність завжди на перших позиціях
там де потрібна допомога і підтримка
коли почалась епідемія коронавірусу
європейська Солідарність та багато
волонтерів спрямували свої зусилля на
запобігання поширенню і подолання
наслідків цієї біди за оцінками
українців саме активність європейської
солідарності є найбільш помітною
запрошую до слова жінку яка про боротьбу
з епідемію і про благодійну діяльність
знає Не з чуток чи новин а з власного
досвіду запрошую до слова лідерку
європейської солідарності у Києві пані
Марину
[оплески]
Порошенко
дорогі друзі колеги
однодумці Сьогодні ми обговорюємо
надзвичайно важливі питання пов'язані з
розвитком країни та громадянського
суспільства і в цьому контексті Я б
хотіла
подякувати ІІ
ілитися ще однією важливою темою темою
благодійності тему яка протягом багатьох
років була і залишається невід'ємною
частиною діяльності нашої родини та
нашої команди фонду Порошенка
європейської солідарності справи громад
та
волонтерів за понад 20 років роботи
фонду порошенк
Нам вдалося реалізувати велику кількість
важливих для країни проектів у сфері
культури це і найбільший світломузичний
фонтан Рошен у Вінниці і центр Анни
київськії у Франції і археологічні
дослідження на місці поховання короля
данили
Галицького у Польщі і будівництва
єдиного за часів незалежності України
театру на Подолі всі ці проекти були
спрямовані на розвиток країни та
популяризації її у
Світі але у
2014 році збройна агресія проти нашої
країни з боку Російської Федерації
змінили життя кожного українця
та поставила Україну перед новим
викликом тримати оборону при фактично
зруйнованій та
обозброєній армії то та
розграбованій країні при повній
відсутності державних коштів саме тоді
п'ятий президент України Петро Порошенко
і Наш фонд направили всі свої зусилля на
допомогу армії системи
протиповітряної оборони озброєння для
десантно-штурмових військ житло для
військових все те що допомогло тоді нам
вистояти вистояти всій
країні
розуміючи важливість якісної та
своєчасної медичної допомоги для наших
гродян ми допомагали будувати нові і
реконструювати старі медичні заклади це
і будівництво нового корпусу дитячого
дитячої лікарні ахмадіту і реконструкція
відділення онкогіматології і
трансплантації кисневого мозку в
національному інституті раку в Києві і
реконструкція багатопрофільної лікарні в
Кременчуці також багато зусиль ми
спрямували на розвиток інклюзивних
навчальних
закладів програми навчання для освітян
створення безбар'єрного середовища та
формування відкритого та толерантного
суспільства лише протягом
2015-2019 років на благодійність та
підтримку української армії нами було
спрямована понад 1, млрда гривень та
2020 рік знову став несподіваним
викликом для всієї
країни пандемія
коронавірусу вона прийшла в Україну і
через повну безпорадність та
непрофесійні дії центральної влади
боляче зачепила кожну українську
родину Тому як і в 14 році ці ми
об'єднали свої зусилля з тисячми
волонтерами та благодійниками стали на
захист медичних працівників хворих на
ковід та соціально незахищених громадян
спрямувавши на порятунок життя українців
сотні мільйонів
гривень лікарям Ми допомагаємо засобами
індивідуального захисту захисними
костюмами противиросними окулярами
масками які сотнями тисяч ми регулярно
завозили в Україну але пріоритетом
роботи нашої команди було налагодити
вітчизняне виробництво захисних костюмів
щоб не тільки забезпечити наших лікарів
захистом за кращими європейськими
стандартами а і створити робочі місця в
Україні Саме таке виробництво ми
запустили в Чернігові
протягом всього часу епідемії медичні
заклади які лікують хворих на
коронавірус ми забезпечували необхідним
обладнанням апаратами штучного і
вентиляції легень
рентген апаратами пульсоксиметрами та
тестами для виявлення коронавірусу Крім
того в останню хвилю пандемії ми
передали до опорних лікарень України
сотні киснев концентраторів для допомоги
тим пацієнтам які без апарата не могли
дихати Саме так ми боремося за життя
кожного українця
[оплески]
тих Також ми не забули і про тих
кого хаотичний і незрозуміли дауни
зеленої влади поставили на межу
виживання і наша команда також не
залишила їх тому впродовж цілого року в
нашому офісі збиралися волонтери і
активісти громадської організації справа
громад фонду Порошенка європейської
солідарності та нашої
Молодіжки які формували набори
необхідних продуктів для пенсіонерів ось
оіб з інвалідністю та багатодітних сімей
за цей час десятки тисяч наборів було
сформовано та передано соціально
незахищеним громадянам з різних куточків
України і
наостанок незважаючи на те що дехто
завершив війну в своїй голові війна
триває а тому разом з вами Ми
продовжуємо допомагати Українській
армії наприкінці травня ми передали на
передову батальйонний комплекс системи
відеоспостереження
це саме те обладнання яке служе очима
нашим захисникам а значить збереже не
одне життя ми можемо звітувати про сотні
мільйонів або навіть мільярд гривень які
витрачає наша родина на благодійність
але не менш важливими і цінними є Кошти
які перераховувають наші
однодумці до прикладу лише за останні
кілька днів понад півторитися наших
громадян перерахували від 9ти до 50 000
грн особистих коштів для захисту і
купівлі
другого батальйонного комплексу
відеоспостереження для 10тої
гірсько-штурмової бригади на
фронті і тому вже найближчими днями ми
зможемо передати його нашим
захисникам допомо допомагати і
захищати було і залишається не просто
гаслом нашої команди Це наше щоденне
життя бо ми завжди там де найважчі і
завжди з тими кому не все однаково А
коли ми разом ніхто і ніщо не зможе нас
здолати тому що ми і є
Україна Слава Україні ером
Слава
Дякую Марину Анатоліївну зараз на екрані
привітання учасникам з'їзду від воістину
народної артистки улюбленої актриси
мільйонів неперевершеної
волонтерки фронтової мами як її ще
називають неповторної Ади
Роговцевої за часів
олесійвича Порошенка почався рух в
кінематографі дуже багато було знято
фільмів хороших фільмів які роблять
честь нашій країні і цей рух треба
продовжувати треба дбати про кіно про
культуру про театр про
виховання наших дітей Тому що ті
одинички які пробиваються як крізь
асфальт квіточка це мало Треба щоб
загальний рівень культури тури був
високи А для цього у
вас члени Партії дуже багато роботи в
європейській Солідарності в мене дуже
багато друзів Там дуже багато зібралося
хороших добрих відблених в Україні людей
хочу побажати
з'їздові успіху в роботі з'їзду і щоб
вона була направлена на те як зробити
кожній людині що живе в Україні
вірити тим хто нами керує тим хто про
нас дбає то всіляко підсилює авторитет
України в світі бажаю вам
[оплески]
[музика]
і продовжуючи актуальну тему розуміємо
що за останні півтора року півтора роки
новітніми героями України стали
лікарі як було колись і що сьогодні
відбувається в сфері української
медицини добре знає медпрацівник депутат
від європейської Солідарності в Черкасах
Олександр Кульбіда запрошую до
[оплески]
слова Слава
Україні я Олександр Кульбіда 13 років
Вибачте дуже
хвилююсь Мої вітання пане президенте
Марина Анатоліївна шановні учасники і
делегати
з'їзду Тепер
[оплески]
заново 13 років свого життя я присвятив
медицині 12 по років на швидкій і
останні сть місяців ковідній реанімації
Черкаської інфекційної Ліка
ситуацію в моєму місті можу описати
Таким чином так справді за останні два
тижні кількість хворих зменшилась в нас
навіть з'явилися вільні
ліжка нашо в нашому медичному закладі є
киснева станція
концентратори засоби індивідуального
захисту для медичних працівників до речі
хочу подякувати фонду Порошенка і Петру
олексійовичу за те що ви вчасно
допомагали
нам із комбінезонами коли їх бракувало з
березня місяця і працюючи на швидкий їх
було недостатньо і я вам дуже вдячний і
від імені медичних працівників теж вам
дякую і за ті концентратори які
врятували І продовжують рятувати тисячі
життів дякую
вам
е за моєю інформацією в нашому місті
закриваються у лікарнях ковідні
відділення е Ну на мою думку це в
зв'язку з тим що можливо трохи
зменшилась кількість хворих е за
неофіційною інформацією лікуванням
ковіда буде займатися тимчасовий
інфекційний стаціонар Який в нас
розгорнутий на базі
ее пологового будинку і резервною буде
Перша міська лікарня зараз цей
тимчасовий інфекційний стаціонар може
прийняти 110 хворих але він може
розгорнутися це ще плюс 40
ліжок як ситуація буде розгортатися далі
з ковідом ну сказати тяжко якщо брати до
уваги такий низькі темпи вакцинації
населення то я думаю що не виключено що
на осінь буде Нова хвиля і все буде
заново Я розумію що кожна країна
переживає чаж тяжкі
часи ці тяж тяжкі часи настали і в нас
дикий сусід який напав на нас війною
ковід ну і ще одна біда в нас декілька
років назад звалилась на нашу голову
але
нічого ми пережили 14-й рік 15-й ми не
боялися Путіна Петро Олексійович Як ви
говорили а ту біду Ми переживем і
[оплески]
поготів так мені і моїм колегам тяжко
Але ми вибрали наш шлях шлях медика і ми
будемо робити все щоб допомогти і
врятувати як якомога більше хворих все
буде Україна Слава
українілава Дякую
друже ви знаєте мені дуже подобається
ее оця типова для українця фраза От якби
тяжко не було якби важко і складно Не
було нічого переживемо і Це пройде і це
минеться і це поборемо як би тяжко не
було завжди українець оглянеце зітхне і
скаже
і це поборемо друзі оцей дух дух
Перемоги дух взаємопідтримки
волонтерської допомоги Він завжди був є
і буде притаманним українцям але саме
тоді в 14му19-му роках попри війну і
складні реформи
українці найбільше почали відчувати себе
справжніми громадянами своєї країни з
готовністю захищати свою землю і
боротися за кожного українця
унікальне відчуття яке Прокинулось на
фоні важкої боротьби України за своїх
політв'язнів і
військовополонених для проведення
панельної дискусії запрошую на цю сцену
сучасних політв'язнів Марію варфоломеєву
Івана Козловського ахтема шейгоза та
члена надскладних переговорів у Мінську
Ірину
[оплески]
[музика]
Геращенко
шановний Петро Олексійович дорогі друзі
Дорогі колеги ви знаєте Велике щастя
бути сьогодні тут в цьому товаристві і
спочатку як співголова фракції
європейської солідарності Я хочу сказати
що ми щасливі в сесійній залі що ми
тепер не один а один плюс п о П1 пс1
плюс в кожному обласному центрі в нас є
фракція і з цим спецназом нам набагато
легше буде боротися за Україну Ми дуже
дякуємо вам насправді друзі це дуже
важливо і знову ідеальна і геніальна
ідея провести з'їзд не перед виборами ми
готові до виборів але в міжвиборчий
період дуже важлива серйозна розмова про
наш досягнення аналіз наших можливо
помилок для того щоб рухати с далі
дійсно Ось ця некомпетентна Влада За два
роки показала своїм дилетантствам що
мода на нових політиків проходить і
приходить мода на нову політику Хто може
дати насправді цей запит нової політики
сильна команда де ми сьогодні бачили
справжніх нових Я пишаюся всіма хто от
перед нами брав слово бо це є Нова еліта
не тільки європейської солідарності а
нашої країни вони відбулися в своїх
професіях в своїх сферах і сьогодні є
гордістю нашої команди Але звичайно
потрібен і досвід і тому наша команда -
Це дійсно та команда яка має стратегію
має план знає як захищати країну дійсно
ви знаєте Я згадую що тут ще це не
звучало але с років тому Петро Порошенко
ледь на запізнився на власну
інавгурацію тому що він не відосики
знімав він до того як ще тільки став
президентом офіційно вже формував
антипутінську коаліцію кувалиї в
нормандському форматі і ми бачимо що
сьогодні Україна втрачає суб'єктність ми
з вами не повинні цього допустити ви
знаєте зараз на сцені сидять люди які не
всі є членами європейської солідарності
але вони наш камертон за якими ми маємо
так само звіряти Чи правильно ми
рухаємося тому що ми однодумці ми
сповідуємо спільні цінності і от так
само як ми з вами сповідуємо наш
камертон наші цінності по армії ми маємо
більше залучати до нашої команди до
наших заходів в усіх регіонах України
переселенців іх людей так само які разом
з нами прагнуть повернути Крим і Донбас
ви знаєте я хочу подякувати нашій
команді за те що коли ми виїжджаємо за
кордон і Петру Порошенко і Іванки
Климпуш і Олексію нку Маши оновій Ірині
фріс всім-всім ми виступаємо там не під
прапором європейської солідарності під
прапором України захищаючи Україну і
дуже важливо щоби сьогодні так само як в
14-му1-му ми боролись за кожного
українця хто сьогодні займається
звільненням заручників Я не знаю Петро
Порошенко Наша команда звільнили тисячі
ми були причетні в рамках Мінського
процесу до звільнення сотень Я дуже
щаслива бачити сьогодні і Марію Я дуже
ба щаслива бачити Ігоря вони наші
камертони і наші такі знаєте талісмани
того що треба рухатись в правильному
напрямку але на кожній зустрічі Сьогодні
ми з вами маємо боротись за українців і
не тільки за українців протасевич
Навальний неважливі прізвища важливо те
що їх уримує режим Путіна і чим
голосніше на всіх майданчиках світу ми
будемо нагадувати про путінський режим і
його злочини тим раніше цей режим піде в
Нікуди і ми переможемо Ми вітаємо
створення
політв'язнями платформи і Ми дякуємо
нашому роману сущенку одному з
ініціаторів цієї платформи політв'язнів
яка сьогодні владі нагадує що треба
боротись за своїх і в нас є пропозиція
щоби резолюцію з'їзду ми з вами
проголосували наступне перше Верховна
Рада України має прийняти законопроект
європейської солідарності про статус
заручників політв'язнів і зниклих без і
е
заручників політм'язнів і
військовополонених їх родини мають мати
підтримку друге від нашого з'їзду ми
маємо проголосувати резолюцію спонукати
українську владу негайно поновити
перемовини з усім світом за звільнення
заручників Зеленський не відосики має
писати він має мати переговори з
байденом і просити його тиснути на
Путіна не тільки про північний потік2 а
й про звільнення всіх заручників
політв'язнів третє резолюція нашого
з'їзду має бути наступна Кримські татари
не можуть бути усунуті від Кримської
платформи Це є ненормально ахтем чий гос
Мустафа джемілієв мають долучитися до
неї а від влади ми маємо почути не
тільки прізвище лідерів яких вони
запросили до Кримської платформи а сенси
якими це буде наповнено І останнє вони
весь час говорять що мають план а б
тільки ми не чуємо цього плану А в нас
цей план є Я хочу нагадати що під час
війни президент Порошенко
дуже чітко заявив про наш план
деокупації Криму і Донбасу перше
посилення армії друге формування
антипутінської коаліції третє і до цієї
теми Влада має повернутися це безумовно
тема миротворців без яких сьогодні
демілітаризація окупованого Донбасу
неможлива Ну і четверте не можна
будувати ніякі канали дом вбухувати туди
державні кошти не можна будувати ніякі
платформи якщо не чути голос людей які
пережили катівню які знають що
відбувається на окупованому Донбасі і
тому я думаю дуже важливо якщо сьогодні
своїми думками для нас для команди яка
формує цю політику реінтеграції і ми
будемо її реалізовувати свій голос Своє
бачення скажуть Ігор Козловський Марія
варфоломеєва агтем чгос Пане Ігоре дякую
Я радий вітати делегатів і гостей з'їзду
Пане президенте пане Марія Маріна ми тут
сидимо не просто так а ми от
з Машею варфоломеєвою Ми ті хто пройшли
котівні на Донбасі пройшли котівні
пройшли підвали пройшли камери
смертників нас катували але нас не
зламали і я щиро вдячний якраз тій
боротьбі яка
відбувалася коли ми знаходилися там в
цих підвалах я пам'ятаю як до мене
приходили опепрацівники і говорили
здивована А ви знаєте і на ви говорили
ви знаєте
там в Америці в Європі за вас говорять
що виступав президент Порошенка Що Ірина
Геращенко піднімає голос Ви що такий
значний я казав що ми всі українці ми
для України є
визначними
я Абсолютно згоден з тим що така
підтримка інформаційна підтримка
підтримка з боку якраз людей які можуть
говорити відкрито на всіх майданчиках і
за кордоном і в Україні і від влади це
надзвичайно важливо це це означає що там
люди які залишаються в підвалах Вони не
залишилися один на один сво бідою що не
залишилися один на один своєю бідою їх
рідні і близькі тут в Україні
які на жаль зараз не можуть витягнути їх
звідти надзвичайно важлива також дійсно
і правова підтримка правова і закон про
статус заручники політв'язнів
військовополоненин він вкрай важливий і
і ми як представники платформи звільнена
політв'яснв про це постійно говоримо
на всіх На всіх в усіх інтерв'ю всіх
майданчиках надзвичайно важлива
гуманітарна допомога тому що люди які
знаходяться там і їх родини Вони часто
не в змозі допомагати їм тому що вже не
вистачає ні сил ні грошій ні яких інших
матеріальних ресурсів Їм потрібна
допомога і також важлива допомога тим
хто повернувся тому що коли ти
повертаєшся це продовження це
продовження твого перебування там
і у тебе немає взагалі нічого Ти
практично залишив все своє минуле там в
де тебе зарештували це твоя домівка це
твоє майно і ти тут починаєш з нуля у
тебе немає де жити у тебе немає за що
їсти і З цим треба також щось робити Я
знаю дуже багато проблем які які є у
наших колишніх
полонених європейська Солідарність - це
про Солідарність про Солідарність людей
і не тільки з Європою але ж і в Україні
також нам потрібна всеукраїнська
Солідарність для того щоб звільнити ці
окуповані території це стосується і не
тільки коли ми говоримо поняття
реінтеграція Це надзвичайно складне і
стратегічне наше завдання В яке сла
можна поділити на декілька таких
складових ну по-перше це реінтеграція і
тих регіонів які знаходяться д контролем
України тому що вони повинні все ж таки
становитися все більше і більше
проукраїнськими по-друге
Це допомога колишнім переселенцям
тіх хто потерпає зараз І це також є
надзвичайно важливими і я думаю що якраз
позиції європейської солідарності тут
це є позиція партії яка усвідомлює оцю
нашу загальноукраїнську проблему дякую
дякую Пане Ігоре Пані
Марія дякую за запрошення і що я хотіла
сказати про інтеграцію реінтеграцію
Донбасу про це дуже багато кажуть і
існує така думка що це покоління вже
втрачено назавжди що вже неможливо
нічого зробити що оці люди вони завжди
будуть нас ненавидіти але насправді Я
так не думаю тому що ми зараз кажемо
Кожного дня я чую про інформаційну війну
війну війну і інформаційна війна вона
така сама ефективна скажемо так як і
війна яка відбувається артилерійськими
чи іншими знарядами тому якщо знаряди
артилерії вбивають людину то так само
людина вбиває її вбиває інформація яка
є зміненим змістом тому якщо е подавати
інформацію на окупований Донбас
правильну Таку як вона є е не про
спалені двері у адміністрації президента
не про якісь там я не знаю там здобутки
антиздобутки вигадані здобутки якоїсь
там вигадані здобутки а дійсно те що
відбувається
то я я не думаю що люди будуть думати
погано я не думаю що так важко повернути
ее розум людей до українського якогось
суспільства тому
[музика]
е-е і
ще Вибачте я хвилююсь
Дякую І що я хотіла ще сказати що
насправді ее це
якоюсь е активних людей таі як Хто
підтримував е
там Росію
чи більшостьі людей Вони живуть за
принципом Какая разница їм все одно будь
то буде Україна будь то буде Росія їм
все одно Тому треба просто
показувати дійсно що відбувається в
Росії про про ті репресії які кожного
дня там катують людей те що люди живуть
там не якісь захмарні зарплати не якісь
там уявні якісь там здобутки Путіна і
так далі люди живуть на 22 000 рублів і
ну це не той рівень на який жителі
Донбаса вони розраховують Вони думають
що в них там буде пенсія на більша
[музика]
ніж на на окупованій країні і Вони
думають що сейчас вот Росія нас заберёт
Россия нас заберёт але насправді ну вони
нічого не отримують з того що вони
розраховують і тому треба От як нам
показува про розіп'ятих хлопчиків так
само емоційно забарвлено треба подавати
ту правду яка відбувається
насправді в Росії то дякую дякую Марія
друзі тобто ви зрозуміли завдання і воно
дуже правильне і спільне інформаційна
війна Ми всі маємо в цій гібридній війні
бути на стороні України і дуже активними
Ми раді що в нашому товаристві сьогодні
вітати Євгена Панова Володимира
Жемчугова Володимира балуха це все наші
побратими з якими разом ми боремося за
Україну і боремося звичайно на
інформаційному фронті а підсумує нашу
коротку дискусію дуже важливий член
нашої команди
ахтем Доброго
дня
я знаєте часто
запитують що треба робити щоб звольнити
наших політв'яз
Я кажу по-перше треба почути за що вони
стали
польтв'язними щоб зрозуміти характер
природу цієї боротьби отут разом зі мною
Володимир іде
Женя ми в Криму декілька років в тюрмі
да були разом Ми там Показували що таке
для нас Україна український народ
як ми пишаємося оцими
досягненнями які вони показували всьму
світу а ми там робили свою справу ми не
соромились кричали Слава Україні в тюрмі
в
Сімферополі і нам
відповідали Героям слава Ми одували
футболки де була написано Україна і і ці
апера
фсбшники намагалися нас зламати Так ми
знали що за нами стоїт Україна за
україной стоїт весь світ того
часу нас
намагалися постійно поприкати
президентом Порошенка А ми пишалися що у
нас є такий лідер і він зараз тут з нами
і він є лідерем України
так
От коли ти зрозумієш чому ми там
опинилися ти будеш знати що робити
президент Порошенко і його команда знали
що робити тому тому за нас не віддавали
всіх цих
мерзотників злочинців так як таких як
цемих як таких як Беркут ми відмовлялися
коли нам такі пропозиції йшли коли ми
були там у ворога в руках ми казали ні
за це ми тут
знаходимось це теж наш фронт це наша
боротьба ми знаємо на що ми йшли і зараз
всі ті хто там сидять в колоніях ми
спілкуємось з ними Вони
що чекають вони від України во тої
потужност от того того тиску якого Путін
От той згуртованості наших партнерів по
світу
Ані того що
там іноді буває соромно за дії
влади яка не розуміє природу нашої бо
боротьби в цих
в'язницях Але я
впевнений що з такою командою і це
не тільки я Я багато де буваю по Україні
і кажу європейсь Солідарність - це
платформа яка об'єднує до якої тягнуться
всі в Україні хто хто за бореться от за
ці символи України і тому я теж в цій
платформі і ми обов'язково цього ворога
переможемо ми звільнимо
всіх і риторії
обов'язково в Криму нас всі чекають
вони Вони не
будуть зупиняти зупиняти
цей спротив окупанту так буде іще кро
кров на жаль але це є
і шлях до перемоги і ми обов'язково
переможемо Слава
Україні Дякую друзі президент Порошенко
давав нам всім одну директиву Україна
своїх не кидає один з найемоційніших
моментів мого життя це коли в окупованій
Горлівці вони по спискам викликали
заручників і говорять Ігор Козловський
стоїть 100 орків у зброї і пан Ігор
говорить Слава Україні і окупована
Горлівка тоді відповіла Героям слава Ми
переконані що разом ми звільнимо Україну
разом ми звільнимо заручників Україна
своїх не
[оплески]
кидає Дуже дякую учасникам дискусії люди
сталевої волі залізної витримки Дякуємо
вам а зараз друзі увага на екран давайте
згадаємо ті пть років які стали роками
справжніх українських перемог сі частини
першої статті 85ї Конституції
України призначити позачергові вибори
президента України на 25 травня
[музика]
року
обраним Президентом України є Порошенко
Петро
Олексійович Настав час не відворотних
позитивних
змін армія та її переозброєння зусиллями
вітчизняного військово-промислового
комплексу має стати нашим найголовнішим
пріоритетом збройні сили Національна
гвардія Державна прикордонна служба
служба безпеки отримали відповідні
накази ми будемо наступати і будемо з
звільняти
на ми не навчимося оборонятися самі і
тепер ми зможемо випускати такі ракети
які здатні летіти значно далі ніж зараз
І це має стримувати нашого ворога бо
його територія теж стає
вразливою нікому не вдасться здолати
Україну ми готові зі зброї в руках
захищати власну землю боротися за кожен
її клаптик і Нікому її віддавати не
збираємося
Слава українському народу Україні
Слава Я використаю весь свій
дипломатичний досвід щоб забезпечити
підписання міжнародного договору який би
прийшов би на заміну Будапештського
меморандуму
ні з ким не може бути компромісу в
питаннях Криму європейського вибору та
державного
устрою
саме європейський досвід підказує нам що
значну частину повноважень вже зараз
треба делегувати з центру місцевим
органам
[музика]
влади реформа щодо децентралізації
розпочнеться вже цього року змінами до
Конституції і україна має все необхідне
щоб забезпечити людям європейський
Добробут піднялася на чотири сходинки у
рейтингу всесвітнього банку doing
Business з Нового року мінімальна
зарплата в Україні може зрости вдвічі
для реалізації наших амбітних планів Нам
потрібні не лише мир та єдність країни
але й консолідація всіх патріотичних
проукраїнських і проєвропейських
сил нації з яким борцям за незалежність
України в XX столітті присвоєна за
статус учасників бойових
[оплески]
дій
звершилося цей день вже увійшов в
історію України як священний день день
створення Автокефальної помісної
Православної церкви України день
остаточного здобуття нашої української
незалежності від Росії та церква що в
місті
Константинополі нас підтримує цілий
світ заради іх цінностей європейських
цінностей 3 по роки тому українці вийшли
на революцію гідності вимагаючи реформ
європейської
інтеграції до
свидания наш ласковий Міша возвращайся в
свой Сказочный
лес народ своє магове слово сказав під
час революційних подій під час спротиву
агресії під час виборів тепер черга за
нами за владою Ми народ що був одірваний
від своєї великої батьківщини Європи
повертаємося до неї остаточно без
поворотно
[музика]
друзі брати і сестри маю честь запросити
до слова п'ятого президента
України лідера партії європейсь
Солідарність Петра
[музика]
Порошенка дорогі друзі дорогі делегати
з'їзду дорогі гості запрошені бойові
побратими волонтери до
добровольці Подивіться скільки нас
багато
і які ми
сильні
які очі Які палають у
вас які величезні завдання ми зробили за
ть
років і як зараз конче
необхідно і захистити наші
здобутки і вести Україну далі до
Європейського
Союзу до добробуту людей до
безпеки до
порядку але зараз Ми вимушені
констатувати що Україна Україна долає
Екватор дуже небезпечного
експерименту
започаткованого два роки
тому українці щодня
розраховуються з власних кишень за
непрофесійність за хаос за управлінську
безпорадність цієї зеленої
команди кожна українська родина платить
за це низькими
зарплатами які не покривають прожитковий
мінімум і не змінюються вже два роки не
індексуючись у зв'язку з
інфляцією пенсіонери платять за це
мізерними
пенсіями кожен українець платить за
хмарними тарифами
які пообіцяли два роки тому збільшити
точніше зменшити вдвічі чи втричі а
насправді зросли на
46% платить за це високими цінами бо
ціни на продукти
харчування зросли за останній рік Май же
вдвічі Зеленій команді байдуже вони по
магазинам не
ходять Але
найголовніше платять втраченими
надіями і
розвіяними
ілюзія і в травневі
дні коли на вулиці
банковій дуже гучно
святкували двохріччя
інавгурації
саме в ці травневі дні на
цвинтері поховали птитисячного
українця А може навіть
150тисяго Як каже Національна академія
наук
поховали того який помер чи ту яка помер
чи померла від
коронавірус я твердо
наголошую що ми не є
популістами ми є відповідальні
державники і ми знаємо що пандемія є в
усьому світі але Уявіть
собі скільки б українців вдалося би
врятувати від цієї жахливої смерті коли
немає чим дихати коли немає
кисню якби в 20-му році замість того
щоби красти навелики
крадівництві кошти ковідного фонду яка в
тому числі і наша фракція сконцентрувала
і
презентувала зеленському і його уряду
були спрямовані на кісневі станції
кісневі концентратори засоби захисту
рентгенпарати ліки
щеплення а не були направлені тільки на
те як вони хотіли набити свої кишені
через вели
дівництво скільки людей вдалося би
врятувати якби з
пандемією боролася би фахова і
компетентна
команда Бо
ви не викликаєте до себе некомпетентного
лікаря своїх дітей ви не довірите
некомпетентному
вчителю а
державу державу на жаль більш як два
роки тому ми доверили довірили
некомпетентній команді і на жаль
пандемія - це не єдина загроза яка
нависає над Україною і потребує
кардинальних
змін в даному випадку в медичній галузі
І ці зміни треба не відкладати не ховати
за
відосиками не пояснювати що їм заважає
або
попередники або лідери іноземних держав
які йому видти не дають чи вакцин чи
обладнання чи
грошей пандемія була світовим змаганням
світових
лідерів і український лідер бездарно
програв поставивши Україну на останньому
місці в
Європі але він абсолютно не відчуває
цього бо заплатили підкреслюю за це це
українці
ми опозиція державницька опозиція і ми
маємо аналізувати ті виклики які стоять
перед країною і давати абсолютно чіткі
відповіді яким чином ці виклики
долати по-перше перший головний виклик
війна бо не вдалося пам'ятаєте зійти з
Путіним десь
посередині стати на коліна для того щоб
побачити в його очах свій мир бо коли ти
стаєш на коліна ти щось інше
[оплески]
[музика]
бачиш Дворічна політика умиротворення
агресора зазнала системного
краху вийди Визнай і покайся перед
людьми
А
зараз як ніколи є величезний ризик
залишитись з агресором сам на
сам бо ти своїми діями
руйнуєш ту коаліцію яка крок за кроком і
день за днем нашою командою будувалася
5ть років і передана були
тоді коли діяли санкції проти Путіна за
Крим санкції проти північного потоку-2
санкції по окупованому Донбасу і Криму
санкції по
mh17 санкції по Керченській
протоці кожен цей крок - це наша
дипломатична
перемога яка зараз так бездарно
розтринькується звинуваченнями в бік
байдена і Сполучених Штатів меркелі і
Німеччини макрона і
Франції і тільки по відношенню до до
Путіна ми не чуємо жодного
коментаря
і
це ця позиція яка продемонстрована
владою внаслідок дипломатичної
безталанності призвела до того що навіть
була продемонстрована неспроможність
отримати перепустку квиток на саміт НАТО
те вже що вважалося рутиною бо з
в кардіфі в Британії і закінчуючи
самітом в брюселі самітом в Варшаві це
було рутинно робота Коли Ну а як же без
України і вже два
роки Україну на це зібрання не
запрошують а Зеленський знову
намагається сховатися від
відповідальності
звинувачуючи Порошенка байдена Меркель
макрона мені не соромно бути в цій
компанії якби від цього не страждала
Україна і Марина правильно сказала і
Ірина що ми виступаємо за кордоном під
українським прапором і на зустрічах з
міжнародними
делегаціями Ми кажемо виключно про
Україну про план дій щодо членства в
НАТО нагадайте ще рік тому вся наша
фракція в Верховній Раді була
звинувачена в тому що ми дарма
піднімаємо питання про план дій щодо
членства в НАТО і Постанову з цього
приводу бо вони не потрібні так вони
тоді казали зараз вони цього соромляться
вони повитирали по всьому
ютбу Петре по ютбу ти правильно сказав і
зорієнтував повитирали зга
про свою незграбність і
некомпетентність і Отже війна і безпека
це те де Україна має об'єднатися для
того щоби як
14му захистити нашу землю захистити нашу
волю захистити нашу долю і друге питання
навколо якого ми має для подолання якого
ми маємо об'єднатися
це бідність українців ікономіч падіння
Української
держави в яке ці дилетанти
занурили нашу
країну ще до пандемії я нагадаю що рівно
с років тому наша команда передала
їм величезний золотовалютний
запас десятки мільярдів гривень в
казначействі 4,5 в економічного
зростання і багато-багато інших речей
починаючи від рейтингу дуєм бізнесу який
зростав рекордно як жодна країна світу
не могла
продемонструвати і порядок денний реформ
де ми реформували країну за 5 років
більше ніж за чверть століття до нас а
зараз зараз Світовий банк і Міжнародний
валютний фонд переглядають в бік погірше
економічні прогрози прогнози України
звертаю вашу увагу в Індії зростання
9,9% в Китаї зростання 9%, в Сполучених
Штатах зростання 7% а в Україні в
Україні зростання
немає хто
[оплески]
винен
друзі я вам підкажу не пандемія бо
пандемія була у всьому
світі і не Порошенко бо може ви не
знаєте но Порошенко вже два роки не
президент хоча Напевно ви цього не
помітили і є ще одна
позиція корупція яка набуває таких
масштабів точнісінько
як в часи
Януковича не далі як четверг команда
Зеленського ми були в
залі ми блокували Ми намагалися
перешкодити команда
Зеленського
скасувала тендерні процедури прозоро які
були запроваджені нашою командою бо вони
дуже їм заважають грабувати на великому
крадівництві і 100 мілрдів гривень 100
Карл 100 млрд були виведені зпід
prozoro на контрактах по будівництву
кільцевої дороги навколо Києва
крадівництво їм заважають здійснювати А
це дорогі друзі п'ята частина Пенсійного
фонду України
це різке
зростання пенсій і
зарплат
і коли на сьогоднішній день Вони
намагаються підвищити
податки Вони намагаються збільшити тиск
силовиків
ми ж це все вже бачили в 13-му році і Це
веде до руйнації державо І це те Чому
наша
партія нашї дружні нам фракції в
Верховній
Раді Дякую присутньому Тут нашому
бойовому побратиму Костенко і партії
голос
друже Ми тебе дуже
любимо це без жартів Бо коли в мене був
суд всі пам'ятають бо більшість з вас
були під печерським судом Я з величезним
задоволенням
побачив справжнього воїна Костенка в
залі такі речі запам'ятовуються надовго
якщо не на завжди Дякую тобі
[оплески]
брате
але що є ключовими європейськими
цінностями які чітко зазначено як
абсолютно ті що образують Європейський
союз їх три
це верховенство права
це
свобода І це
демократія Мені здається це також три
ключові позиції які вивели людей на
помаранчеву революцію і на революцію
гідності от
зараз Зелена Влада планує здійснити
потужну атаку і на верховенство права і
на свободу і на
демократію ще один виклик окреслився
зараз це тенденція до авторитаризму і
згортання
демократії Це загроза тій гідності за
яку наші українські громадяни відстояли
під час Революції
гідності
небезпека правам українців якім ще з
козацьких часів Воля була понад усе і
цим ми
відрізняємося від росіян в яких
цар А в нас
гетьман і це велика
відмінність
і подивиться зараз у всіх навіду
досвід наших сусідів
Білорусі і дуже-дуже невелика відстань
від так званого народного
президента над яким сміялися але його
сприймали тому що сподівалися невідомо
на ще на що і дуже коротка відстань
міжнародного
президента і диктатора параноїка
в то що Во що зараз
перетворилася дружня нам
Білорусі Я Хочу наголосити Ніколи в це
не перетвориться
Україна український народ цього не
дасть багато зазіхали і я прошу дужно
уважно вивчити досвід Януковича
починаючи від конституційного заколоту і
захоплення Конституційного Суду і аж до
квитков до
Ростова що б вони робили в Україні це
завжди завершується саме
цим і це ще пів біди коли на жоден з
викликів офіс президента немає
відповідної адекватної
відповіді справжнє лихо коли Влада сама
по собі є загрозою національної безпеки
України
пам'ятаєте дуже відому фразу президента
Рональда
рейгана свого часу на п'ятому курсі я
писав тоді ще заборонену роботу
спецхрану по
рейганоміки так от тоді президент Рейган
сказав ця Влада не розв'язує проблеми
країни ця влада і є нашою
головною проблемою пан Зеленський не
здогадуєтесь про кого
це і дорогі друзі
ті хто зібралися Наша команда на цей
фантастичний
з'їзд бо і Віка Віка Дякую тобі за
класну організацію і Наташа і
Дінара
вони не переживали за вас дорогі
друзі вони переживали за
дощ я єдиний Хто сказав Не переживайте
Все буде добре Бо господь з нами так і
[оплески]
сталося а з цією
підтримкою ми маємо бути дуже-дуже
відповідальними Бо саме європейська
Солідарність має захищати права
соціальні і політичні українського
народу не допустити остаточного втрату
інтересів до України з боку наших
ключових західних
партнерів бо втрата заходу означає
прихід сюда Росії по-іншому не буде в
природі не існує
вакуум і для того щоби нам не загубити
їх підтримку для того щоби нам
забезпечити і втримати в робочому стані
світову проукраїнську коаліцію яку
створила Наша команда для того щоби
повернути
Україні наше європейське майбутнє для
того щоби зберегти для України
перспективу членства в Європейському
Союзі
забезпечити план дій щодо членства в
НАТО і мабутні членство в
НАТО нам треба об'єднатися і працювати І
за для цього ми зібрали
з'їзд адже я маю констатувати
об'єктивно риторика влади за від початку
до першої Поло до завершення першої
половини її терміну
змінилася риторику нарешті через 2 з по
роки вони нарешті обрали
правильно от є одна
проблема це все рівно як пан Зеленський
тупцюється на На цьому
тренажорі і задишка є і
температура і хекає і
втомлюється тільки на місці
стоїть Це нам не
підходить нам потрібен реальний рух
вперед який ми демонстрували 5ть
років ми знаємо як це робити і ми
зробимо Це цією
командою
Я готовий повірити
що тільки не ображайтеся Я готовий
повірити що Зеленський десь там тихо
вночі мріє не
тільки розправитись з Порошенко А мріє і
привести Україну до
Євросоюзу Але я точно знаю я точно бачу
що він не знає
як це знаєте як
хоче але не може Ну ви знаєте про кого
це
Наполеон казав що найбільша аморальність
- це братися за справи якою не вмієш
робити Ну тут Володимир Олександрович
мав би знати ці слова бо в другосортній
російській комедії він колись грав роль
Бонапарта але чомусь
пропустив не знаєш як
Спитай або не
заважай шановні
делегати Дорогі українці які дивляться
нас по телебаченню
Петя які дивляться нас в Ютубі все
більше і більше в Ютубі нас
дивляться і Андрій і маруся і всі які
розповсюджують правду про нас в
соціальних
мережах Я маю
визнати мій виступ
виглядає Ну виходить так доволі
критично але
правдиво бо ми єдині хто каже правду
їм в очі ми
опозиція і очевидно політична
європейська функція опозиції вказувати
владі на її
провали як би Влада не намагалася з нами
боротися але Хочу наголосити ще раз ми
зібралися тут з іншою метою бо сьогодні
вже всі
побачили до чого веде зелена команда
України 92 українців
відчули пониження і погіршення
фінансового стану в зв'язку з підняттям
цін підняттям
тарифів Так звана
постанова страсної п'ятниці от Господи
слухайте навіть такі асоціації Вони не
розуміють забрала в 4 мльйонів українців
право на
субсидію те що ми в 15му 16 роках
захистили українців Ну не знаєте як
спитайте мова
йдеться про більше як де це це не тільки
україн це домогосподарстві і мова
йдеться про велику кількість більше 20%
українського
населення і Отже наше завдання
відшліфувати план наших дій на
найближчий
рік-два наше з вами завдання не тягну
ковдру на себе але об'єднавшись з нашими
партнерами по демократичному колу
об'єднавши всі зусилля сформувати
потужну коаліцію опозиційних
проєвропейських сил яка поверне країні
професійну
владу врятує країну від хаосу
некомпетентності і ілітантизму
владу яка буде здатна на відміну від
уряду Зеленського вирішувати
найскладніші проблеми як зовнішні так і
внутрішні бо люди не мають
страдати і ми повинні мати всі
можливості для того щоби захистити
це А чого зараз мріє
Зеленський він мріє про другий
термін бо він страшно боїться вийти з
свого офісу
бо треба буде
відповідати дуже сумні новини майже 60%
українців не хотять вашого другого
терміну Володимир
[оплески]
Олександрович бо поки що ви два роки
трималися на той спадщині Яка Наша
команда залишила вам після 14-19 років
ви за визнанням
наших партнерів зараз робити бекслайд
реформ і не Байден винен в тому що
процес вступу в НАТО
зупинився і не Байден Меркель чи макрон
винні в тому що ви зруйнували
співробітництво з міжнародними
фінансовими
організаціями і не Байден макрон Чи
Порошенко винні в тому що ви збільшуєте
кожен Квартал на мільярд доларів
державний борг для того щоби вкрасти на
великому крадівництві А треба віддати
собі належне пройшло половину
терміну для того щоби всі українці могли
зробити висновок
що з цього
Роя не вийде
[оплески]
нічего але ми готові об'єднуватися за
дляля украї
і кажуть поганий тот солдат який не мріє
стати генералом і погана та опозиція яка
не
здатна
забезпечити реалізацію владних
повноважень
ми готові для цього ми це доказали
протягом пти років і подивитьсяся яка
фантастична команда зараз в європейській
солідарності які неймовірні люди прийшли
до нас внаслідок нашої Перемоги на
місцевих виборах в жовтні Минулого
року ми
точно знаємо як захистити країну від дій
недолугої
влади Бо у нас з вами є абсолютно чіткий
план яка будується на нашій компетентній
програмі як захистити людей як
турбуватися про людей яким чином
забезпечувати зростання мінімальної
заробітної
плати з 15го по 19-й рік середня
заробітна плата в країні зросла В 2 З по
Рази за 4
роки при
вас самі
подивиться з 15го по 19-й рік мінімальна
заробітна плата зросла в три рази при
вас самі
Подивіться бюджети розвитку про який
казав міський голова міста Рівне
зросли в
9115 разів при вас впали бо ви забрали
їх ніяк не
нажеретеся
[музика]
і решта
остання більше ДХ третин українців
оцінюють економічну ситуацію в Україні
зараз як погана це вирок вирок вашому
уряду пан
Зеленський Я Хочу наголосити
що 60% українців вважають що за останні
два роки їх фінансове положення
погіршилося це ті яким ви
обіцяли що нарешті
для
України завершиться епоха бідності
виявляється ви мали на увазі Україну
95го
кварталу але
90% українців дуже бо звісно сприймають
ту економічну ситуацію
яка розвивається
зараз
вже твердо переконані що ми маємо на
сьогоднішній день за рахунок коштів
державного
бюджету дати можливісті захистити
українців і це я коли називаю цифри Я не
хочу вам їх
втомлювати вам вас їми втомлювати але я
Хочу наголосити це всі без виключення
соціологічні компанії і ви не врятуєте п
п'ятничними неконституційними
відосиками правду про положення
людей
бо бо для того щоб це зрозуміти
достатньо просто виїхати в
регіони поїдьте на
Донбас тільки без вашої
ро з бронежилетами не по
розміру а просто Підійдіть до людей
поспілкуйтеся дізнайтеся чим
живуть від кропівницького до
Ужгорода від Львова до
Харкова ви не знаєте ж не знайдете
жодного
регіону
я маю право і можливість так
стверджувати тому що десяток тисяч людей
в тому числі серед тих хто присутній на
цьому з'їзді займалися допомогою
людям ту допомогу про яку казала
Марина від інституту рака до лікарні
Ахмадет від лікарні в Кременчузі до
поставок кисневих концентраторів від
цифрових рентген апаратів до апаратів
штучної вентиляції легень від засобів
захисту до найсучаснішого
обладнання лише ви кошти з
коронавірусного фонду крали для чого
щоби
щомісяця по 6-7 мільйонів доларів
заносити вашиій ненажерливій
монобільшості в Верховній Раді
купуючи їх голоси і знищуючи
парламентаризм в Україні з твердим
наміром щоб коли була
дискусія робити парламентську
президентську республіку як по
Конституції є зараз чи президентську
парламентську ви вирішили будувати
корупційно-офісну
президентську це не
получиться Як би ви не намагалися
знищити конституційний суд Як ви не
намагалися порушувати Конституцію
видаючи зловживаючи Владу і скоюючи
злочин видаючи неконційні
е укази я твердо переко
що це точно треба
зупиняти І як це зупиняти ми
знаємо Ще раз наголошую в умовах цієї
безпрецедентної кризи Країна має
об'єднатися країна має набрати абсолютно
рішучий поштовх сформувати нарешті
справжніх
управлінців політично
відповідальних вирішити питання
ситуації з енергетикою захистити ядерну
енергетику визначити питання
з
нашими розвитком поглибленої та
всеохоплюючої зони вільної торгівлі з
Європейським Союзом
і я думаю
що ми маємо зупинити і ваші податкові
новації з якими ви хочете наступного
тижня виходити до Верховної Ради можу
назвати лише одну
друзі внесений законопроект яким Вони
збираються на 20% підвищити ціни на
квартири які купують під час нового
будівництва на
20% за
що що поганого вам зробили українці що
ви так ставитесь до
них обкласти їх ще й
ПДФО для того щоб зробити квартири до
дорожче на третину і так українці не
мають на сьогоднішній день
можливості забезпечити собі власне житло
відкрийте
серце всі бачили Минулого тижня як ми
повернулися з Донбасу більшість
правда хто дивиться російські телеканали
вони це зв'язали тільки з полуничкою і
те що Ірина геращенка з'їла три
Полунички з тих ящиків які ми дарували
солдатам але насправді насправді ми
робили дуже-дуже важливу
функцію коли ми
забезпечували українських військових Су
над сучасним електронним обладнанням які
рятує батальйонний комплекс
спостереження з приборами ночного
бачення з зумом на 10 км з неймовірними
фантастичними українського виробництва
комплексами і
в цих умовах Коли ти маєш можливість
поспілкуватися І ми мали неймовірну
зустріч в Покровську я можу твердо
переконатися європейську Солідарність
підтримують по всій
країні і тільки європейська Солідарність
бореться і ми це продемонстрували на
87му
окрузі коли легендарна Софійка
легендарна Маруся звіробій зняла свою
кандидатуру для того щоби кандидат від
демократичних сил
переміг А в нас вкрали перемогу коли СБУ
вдерлася в окружну виборчу комісію
вкрила
мішки з бюлетенями і просто вкрала
звідти
бюлетень кандидат якого ми підтримали
навіть не
бореться і Виявляється що боремося
Лише ми Отже наша
вимога
негайно зменшити податковий тиск негайно
запроваджити трьорічний мораторій на
нові податки за винятком одного
запровадити податок на виведений капітал
який ми
розробили для того щоби те ті гроші що
вкладаються в розвиток виробництва
підвищення продуктивності праці мали
нульову ставку оподаткування
і щоб це було тим економічним драйвером
який запустить економіку так як ми це
запустили з 14го по 19 он спитайте в
Олега снютки як ми запускали японських
інвесторів під час війни по створення
десятків тисяч нових робочих місць А що
зараз А зараз Україна інвестори
тікають Бо коли розчерком пера
незаконної неконцій рішення рмбо в
інвестора можуть теоретично все забрати
без верховенства
права яка мотивація йти в Україну от
вони і не йдуть і тому у нас найнижчий
за всі роки незалежності показник прямих
іноземних інвестицій інвестиції тікають
з України і заходять лише
спекулятивні на купівлі високодоходних
облігацій державної внутрішньої позики
за які платимо ми з вами
податків ми маємо ще одну пропозицію для
малих та середніх підприємств для малого
та середнього
бізнесу знизити ставку єдиного податку
для тих в кого видатки складають видатки
на заробітну платню складають більше
50% треба стимулювати щоб люди
отримували більше заробітних
плати Ми пішли тоді в
році ви пам'ятаєте на подвійне
скорочення податку на додану вартість з
15-го в Україні автоматично
компенсується податок на додану вартість
А
зараз вони і це руйнують і з'явилося вже
затримка в компенсації ПДВ ви можете це
легко побачити по
статистиці стверджую що у нас є
можливості стимулювати створення нових
робочих місць і це не є інвестиційною ня
бо єдиною в країні інвестиційною
нянію є пан Зеленський і для одного в
його розумінні патрона це
Коломойський це абсолютно не те чого
хочуть побачити
інвестори Я хочу окремо
наголосити нам треба крім дуже важливих
для нас армії мови і віри
додати турботу про людей додати заходи
для забезпечення безпеки держави і
додати захист соціальний захист
українців ми не дамо і не дозволимо
грабувати
лю Зараз дуже великі питання ставляться
по закону по
землі і ви знаєте ми завжди були по
запровадженню ринка землі а але ми
нікому не дамо грабувати людей примусово
вилучати в них землю і я звертаюся до
наших обласних організацій негайно
організувати юридичні антирейдерські
консультації для того щоби захистити
людей від злочинних рейдерських дій
[оплески]
влади друзі ще раз спілкування з нашими
фантастичними неймовірними обласними
організаціями показує коли ми ми
об'єдналися ми можемо все І я хотів би
завершити на дуже-дуже показовій
речі чим має відрізнятися і буде
відрізнятися наша
партія наша партія буде відрізнятися тим
що вона є відкритаю
що вона не є як в окремих областях
закритим клубом коли міжду собою
хтось вирішує якісь питання ми будемо
починаючи з Жовтня абсолютно
позбавлятися таких
людей
Всі хто пов'язує з нами надію на рух
України до Європейського Союзу на рух
України в НАТО Надії на європейські
реформи Надії на протидії
некомпетентності і злочинності влади
повинні мати можливість приєднатися до
нашої
партії і я хотів би вас повідомити що
одразу же після мене Я буду просити до
слова лідера нашої найкращої серед усіх
молодіжок України і світу нашої
Молодіжки європейської солідарності є її
представники У нас тут на
з'їзді ану-ка сильні
кані от послухайте Дінара йди до мене
[музика]
[оплески]
і я хочу сказати що
недарма ми прийняли рішення в партії
розробити абсолютно нову спеціальну
платформу Де кожен депутат від
європейської солідарності На цьому етапі
І вже через декілька тижнів кожен
партієць буде мати можливість на цій
платформі перше мати зворотній зв'язок
для того щоби висловлювати свої позиції
Їх точно почують обговорювати і бути
проінформовані про ті ініціатива які
партія висуває як лідируюча опозиційна
політична
сила завести абсолютно ефективну
координацію наших дій як в обласних
радах в місцевихра
Верховній Раді
України Я думаю що це буде абсолютно
небачена ситуація серед українського
політичного життя Але буде ще одним
доказом що ми з вами є справжньою
крутою поки що опозиційною але
лідируючою політичною силою України
найкращою така як наша партія
європейська Солідарність і
зараз
І зараз я хочу
наголосити чому я в цьому впевнений бо
ми ми є єдина команда крута
драйвова правильна
європейська мене навіть попросили щоби я
в джинсах вийшов що у нас є абсолютно
вже
інший інший іміж партії Ми теж
Міняємося Ми теж позбавляємося тих
хто не поділяє наші
цінності Ми теж намагаємося бути
переконливими ми разом з
тим це не просто зовнішній вигляд Ми
команда з колосальним досвідом вирішення
найскладніших проблем України і світу Ми
команда з абсолютно чітким баченням
стратегії планів І абсолютно чіткими
рецептами їх вирішинти
Ми команда переможців ми з вами
переможемо переможемо заради України
переможемо заради українців які чекають
цієї Перемоги переможемо разом з іми
українцями Слава Україні Героям слава
Отже хочеш змінити Україну міняйся сам і
про ці зміни
Я буду просити розповісти нашу дінару
прошу Діна зараз я думаю ми Петро
олексійвич Дуже дякую вам Я думаю
що для того щоб зрозуміти що буде
відбуватися далі я дуже прошу включити
презентацію
ЄС
[оплески]
[музика]
платформи
[оплески]
[музика]
Вау я просто неймовірно пишаюсь що яє
частиною цієї команди в мене просто
розривають зараз емоції тому що ми цього
моменту чекали дійсно
півроку і знаєте в мене закрадається
питання Коли я бачу всіх
тут сьогодні в чому наша
суперсила І знаєте Я знайшла цю
відповідь тут Наша суперсила в кожному з
нас наша суперсила в тому що ми зараз
стаємо сучасними Подивіться на навіть ці
бейджи тут з'явились
qr-коди у нас немає цієї знаєте
нафталіновості ми можемо грати разом з
депутатами в шахи ми можемо відпочувати
ми можемо драйвити ми можемо показати що
ми круті ми сучасні Та чого ж забираємо
європейські єдине розуміння чому ми все
це робимо тому що європейська
Солідарність - Це
дійсно та платформа де можуть
створюватись унікальні проекти Мені
здається що
ЄС платформа
показала
стовідсоткову готовність до прозорості
та відкритості
єс-платформа показала що
ми готові до змін тому що світ стає
супер сучасним пригадуєте нам обіцяли
країну в смартфоні Нам казали що все
буде круто Отак от digitл а в результаті
що ми отримали нічого до цього ще дуже
далеко але ми точно зараз сього
дні будуємо партію яка
24х7 онлайн в твоєму
телефоні в твоєму планшеті в ноутбуці
буде принцип простий взяти і
зробити коли ми почали розробляти ЄС
платформу концепт взагалі ідею
пам'ятаєте Петро Олексійович сіли ми з
вами 30 грудня
десь І я побачила в Ваших очах і в ваших
словах таку впевненість що так і має
бути так і має працювати партія має бути
більша відкрита ближча до
громад але багато людей навколо чесно
признаюсь казала що Та навіщо вам Це
треба це дуже складно ніхто її не буде
цю платформу заповнювати тобто шукали
якісь відповідь для того щоб це не
робити Петро Олексійович сказав робимо
ЄС платформа створена для того
щоб зробити кооперацію
комунікацію співпрацю з нашими громадами
осередками з нашими депутатами з нашими
партійцями в один клік простою
зрозумілою і без всякого пафосу це
двостороннє по суті інформування це по
суті синтез інструментів який дозволяє
нам бути почутими та бути
видимими Тепер це буде дуже просто коли
ти крутий депутат і це бачать Всі тепер
не сховатися і не сказати що я там щось
робив а в результаті ні Да ми прагнемо
стовідсоткової прозорості Ми прагнемо
стовідсоткової кооперації з нашими
партійцями рейтинги і система
заохочування яку ви бачили в презентації
вона створена для того щоб не
загубити тих зірок які насправді серед
тисячі наших патійців наших однодумців
наших депутатів
є ми налаштовані на те щоб показати свою
силу силу в єдності і знаєте Нещодавно я
вам розкрию так так само такий елемент
який мене просто вразив Я відкриваю с
платформу заходжу в рейтинги хотіла
подивитися наскільки вже вона заповнена
і почала Там просто переклікувати
прізвища і поба чила що в одній з
районних рад є депутатка жіночка я
зайшла на її профіль Вона потрапила в
топйтингу А я дивлюсь вона стільки
всього робить але я її не знала
ніколи вона робить Стільки активносте
вона активна депутатка вона в соціальних
мережах але про неї ніхто не знає а
тепер вона є в єс-платформі Я застрягла
так на пару годин і почала дивитися всі
профілі і ви знаєте пару ідей Я навіть
собі вкрала тобто я взяла собі тому тому
що це було унікально Тому що це вже
працює і ви знаєтеперше що спало мені на
думку
Бінго That's How it should Work все і я
зрозуміла що це те це те чого так не
вистачало людям не вистачало інформації
про партію наші позиції не вистачало які
у нас заходи проходять А зараз все це
відкрито ви знаєте Виходить так що ми
весь цей час намагались бути в якісь
бульбашці але зараз ця бульбашка луснула
тепер ми відкриті бо світ цього вимагає
єзплатформа - це унікальний продукт
знаєте чому Тому що на всьому
українському
політичному там середовищі нема такої
інакшої платформи яка би об'єднувала
стільки людей і давала би таку
кооперацію але таке є в європейських
країнах і політичних структурах
європейських країн це тільки може
свідчити про те що європейська
Солідарність - це та політична партія
яка впроваджує найкращі західні та
європейські практики в Україні на своєму
власному
прикладі бо
ми з вами разом дихаємо в ритмі
тенденцій ви напевно подумаєте
що ця платформа створювалась і за спиною
цієї платформи стоїть купа-купа людей і
компаній а насправді ця платформа і за
шимою цієї платформи стоїть стоять
люди звичайна маленька команда яка кожен
день Дихала цією ідеєю надихалася шукала
рішення це прогресивна команда
однодумців Я хотіла би подякувати і
прошу вас
підтримати людей які і пліч-опліч
працювали над цим продуктом і вдень і
вніч і перша
людина
яка знаєте нічого іншого не робила і
думала про це кожен день Це Ірина
шатохіна давайте їй
поаплодуємо людина яка є співідеологом
по суті цієї платформи і концепту ви
знаєте наші кома конді є ще дівчина яка
навчила нас купі нових it термінів які
ми ніколи напевно не знали і завдяки цій
дівченці і 3к гouп сьогодні ця платформа
вже працює Тому Катя Ющенка дякуємо
[оплески]
тобі ви напевно знаєте я сама з міста
Дніпра і дуже приємно коли однопартійці
підтримують у всіх твоїх початках
починаннях і
підставляють своє сильне плече тому
Каміль прямаков дякуємо вам за
підтримку але ще є люди які ночами не
спали малювали це працювали це дизайнери
Віталік Жека наша Жека просто Відправляю
тобі зі сцени сердечко тому
що так віддаватися своїй праві справі
треба ще
міти команді яка взялася Зараз
адмініструвати цю платформу це Сергій
Таран і Даня Маршалок дуже дякує
вам але ви знаєте головне кому я хочу
подякувати це людині яка до останнього
дня вірила в те що це буде Вау що це
буде масштабно що це буде круто Петро
Порошенко і знаєте що я дуже мрію аби ця
платформа допомогла так само як і мені
реалізувати свої проекти Бо саме ця
платформа дозволяє бути почутим дозволяє
подавати свої ініціативи дозволяє
долучатись до всіх івентів ця платформа
відкрита Для вас ця платформа створена
для вас тільки задумайтесь тут кожен
може стати частиною чогось
Великого тому що європейська
Солідарність - це платфор
[музика]
[оплески]
можливостей Дякую дуже
що ж друзі підходячи до завершення
символічно
привітання про майбутнє від ректора
українського католицького університету
доктора філософії Богдана праха увага на
екрани зразу після Революції гідності
була велика потреба в суспільстві щоби
наголос поставити як на державних
інституціях так на відновленні тих
інструментів Які би
допомогли нашіх бішї такі гідності
українцям привернути ми говоримо про
мову говоримо про туру зараз ці реформи
які були розпочаті які були криком
Майдану ці реформи десь зупинилися такі
враження що ми робимо крок за кроком
десь назад це дуже небезпечно і тому
всім нам на сьогоднішній день треба
об'єднуватися бути спільно разом
і цінувати те що ми мали досі цінувати
те що ми виборювали за що і на майдані і
пізніше захисті нашої країни віддавали
життя наші молоді люди і ми робимо
все увеситет щоби до цього не допускати
щоби підтримувати всі ініціативи такі
які десь відновлюють відроджують
гідність кожному
[музика]
українці друзі Ми сьогодні говорили про
майбутнє про міцний фундамент який ми
заклали для на нашого з вами впевненого
майбутнього ми говорили про важливі речі
ми говорили про зміни Про реформи про
інновації ми говорили про ту Україну Про
яку ми мріємо яку ми хочемо яку ми
любимо друзі зараз Я
запрошую всім разом стати до виконання
державного гімну
України Ще не
вмерла України
ні слава ні воля
Ще нам браття
українці
усміхнеться
доля Згинуть наші
воріженьки як
Росана на
сонці
запанує міми браття у своїй
сторонці душуй
тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободу І
покажем що ми
браття
козацького роду
душу й
тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободу І
покажем що ми
братя
козацького ро
ду Слава Україні сва слава Слава нації
дорога
Україна
Путін зе